Joe Biden is admitting that he is being
tested regularly you know we're all
waiting on these tests and we're leading
the world in tests he's not being tested
for coronavirus no no he's being tested
for something far more important to him
in his campaign he's being tested for
cognitive decline last question real
quick some have speculated that you that
you are subject to some degree of
cognitive decline I'm 65 I don't have a
word recollection that I used to have I
forget my train of thought from time to
time you got 12 years on me sir art have
you been tested for some degree of
cognitive decline I've been testing them
constantly testing look all you know all
I got to do is watch me and I can hardly
wait to compare my cognitive capability
to the cognitive cake bully of the man
I'm running against thank you so much
the man I'm running against whose name I
just can't happen to remember right now
I know what sistah is Ronald ursa I
don't know it's something anyway I'm
running against him he's something like
that probably would have had a stronger
effect
had he not opened his answer with a joke
about lying dog-faced pony-soldiers the
cognitive decline is clear and the
cognitive decline makes the campaign
clear this lockdown this no debates no
rallies this coronavirus is the Biden
campaign we'll get into it I'm Michael
Knowles is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
I think well Joe Biden is on a cognitive
decline all the rest of us are becoming
we're entering into a cognitive incline
we're beginning to realize what this
whole last three months is really about
at least from the perspective of the
media and from politicians first though
we had a question yesterday which was
will the fourth of July be the next
cancellation actually we'll talk a
little bit about that today best comment
though is from Paul which is of course
the 4th of July will be canceled Michael
these Marxist basement dwellers have
always had an aversion to independence
yeah they're just not capable of it
question today would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments the VP race
obviously heating up who do you think
sleepy Joe will be told to pick as his
running mate
I look forward to your answers both the
funny answers and the real answers I
would like to know Joe Biden had not
held a presser for 88 days 88 days
you'll notice is just about the whole
length of the lockdown and the Biden
campaign had never done better you know
before that lockdown campaign looked
really bad Trump was leading him
everywhere now 88 days later all of a
sudden in national polls and in the
swing state polls Trump's campaign is
down Biden's campaign is up Biden's
campaign is up because nobody's seen Joe
Biden he has been hiding out in a
basement and if he could hide out there
until November third he certainly would
do that he finally comes out he's got
hand-picked reporters in the room he
still takes a relatively tough question
which is just are you in cognitive
decline he doesn't know how to answer it
and doesn't answer it convincingly then
it's just one mistake after another so
it's a very open to the conference right
this is the moment you want to project
confidence when you want to show on back
forget about those 88 days that I've
been hiding Biden accidentally admits
that his campaign hand-picked all the
reporters and told him to look out for
certain reporters and to only call on
the easy ones I'm happy to take
questions if you have
he gave me a list how to recognize his
Alex AP out there that's the part you're
not supposed to say I think the name
also has a lens not Alex but that's
neither here nor there you're not
supposed to say that they gave you a
list of people to recognize and only
call on the easy ones and then he did
get easy questions just consider this
two days ago during a White House press
briefing press secretary Kelly Makani
was asked the question of whether
President Trump was upset that the
Confederacy lost the Civil War that was
an actual question a White House press
briefing compare that kind of
questioning to these softballs for Joe
Biden I was told by NBC Mike it's my
great relief he doesn't have to follow
me every day around the country last
time a lot of us saw you on the campaign
trail you were still locked in a very
difficult nomination battle the polls
though today show you with a sizeable
national lead a lead in a lot of the
states that are critical in the
electoral college
I wonder where do you think the race
stands at this moment what keeps you up
at night as you look ahead and can you
maintain this advantage without
campaigning in a traditional way
especially this fall when voters begin
to really tune in do you think that
you'll be able to just be as successful
and wonderful as you are right now do
you think you'll be able to keep doing
that mr. vice president hard-hitting
questions there from NBC News it's the
sort of question that we can come to
expect you know I I think that the Trump
campaign and the President had made some
missteps during this lockdown we'll get
into what some of those are in just a
moment but you can't discount the media
here the fact is during a real
presidential campaign Joe Biden would if
he wouldn't be asked to have questions
by reporters he would make mistakes
himself but what this coronavirus
locked-down has managed to do is cancel
the campaign so he hasn't had to do that
this is his first press conference in
three months and is probably not gonna
be doing a second one anytime soon so he
gets these easy questions then he's
asked how to get Americans on the same
page since everything now in
the virus has become so woeful II
politicized well I think the way to get
on the same page is to I'm gonna try to
say this politely is to lower the
rhetoric based on division stop
appealing to the
the less healthy side of society that's
embarrassing that's an embarrassing
answer one because he doesn't have an
answer to the question right he says
we're gonna lower we're gonna lower it
by lowering the rhetoric and but he he
both doesn't have an answer like he
hasn't thought of an answer and he also
can't come up with an answer because
he's obviously in cognitive decline and
has I don't think we're telling tales at
a school I don't think I'm an armchair
psychologist he can't finish an English
sentence but think about what he what he
did manage to say see what he said was
we're gonna lower rhetoric the usual way
to bring Americans together the usual
way to bring people together in politics
is to make your argument clearly give
your vision for the country and then
your opponent gives his vision for the
country and then whichever vision of the
country you're the people want that's
the one they go with but Joe Biden then
have a vision for the country doesn't
have any answers to these questions his
answer is lower the rhetoric which means
reduce the politics reduce the amount
that we're discussing reduce the power
of the people reduce the freedom of the
people to choose their own leaders and
to choose their own path this has been
the leftist premise for a hundred years
now take the important questions out of
politics give them to experts usually
wearing lab coats and one of those we
have coming up and then we don't need to
worry about all this political rancor
that is what the liberal establishment
and is there any greater representative
of the liberal establishment than Joe
Biden that's what they're selling you is
a politics without politics and then Joe
Donald Trump comes along and ruins their
plans because he actually brings up some
questions about immigration about trade
about how we govern ourselves about what
institutions of the government actually
make the rules
he shakes up the system and says hold on
you've had a lot of your power taken
away people and Joe Biden comes in and
says the way I'm gonna bring people
together I'm gonna lower the amount of
politics that we have all together no
campaigns probably no debates no nothing
just a rigged system to get him into
office and it was at this moment that I
realized what this whole lockdown is
really about which we'll get to in one
second but first I want to thank our
friends over a blink sale the
revolutionary invoicing so
where it is changing the landscape for
small businesses and independent
contractors everywhere you should not
have to send nagging emails to get your
invoices paid when I was freelancing
even today I still do some work on
contract and I always forget to send the
invoices and then I forget to follow up
with blink sale you can send beautiful
customer in and invoices and estimates
within seconds you can stay on top of
your outstanding invoices let your
customers and clients easily pay your
invoices online you'll even get instant
notifications when a customer opens your
invoice so that you'll know if they're
actually just trying to avoid paying you
forget about using invoice templates or
stressing about coordinating a bunch of
different software programs blink sale
takes care of it all so you can spend
more time focusing on the work that
actually gets you paid and actually
makes your business a success definitely
go check it out see for yourself try
blink sale for free at blink sale comm
slash Knolls that is bli NK s al e comm
slash Knowles blink sale spend less time
filling and more time doing what you
love at this point in the biden presser
I realized what the coronavirus lockdown
is all about we talked yesterday about
how it there's no medical purpose to the
lockdown anymore
the point of the lockdown was not to
stop the virus or to cure the virus
right what isn't it's it couldn't
possibly achieve that the only point was
to flatten the curve not overwhelm
health care system we never even came
close to overcome overwhelming the
health care system we did that we
achieved the only thing the lockdowns
could achieve the only purpose of the
lock downs at this point could be
political and what's the political
purpose it occurred to me yesterday that
the lockdown is Biden's campaign it's
the whole campaign how did I figure this
out because Joe Biden mentioned during
this presser first run in 88 days he's
not going to campaign he's not gonna
hold rallies he's she cares so much
about his fellow Americans that he's
gonna sit at home until he wins the
presidency by default well you know I
this is the most unusual
campaign I think in modern history in
that but I start off with the premise
like that I'm gonna follow the docs
orders not just for me but for the
country and that means that I am NOT
going to be holding rallies I am NOT
going to be for example you all are here
but thank the school has put those
circles around so we keep the social
distancing everybody has masks on as
soon as I finish this I'll put my mask
back on and so it's all been almost all
been virtual although I have gone to
Euston I have gone into Pennsylvania I
have gone to have travel but what I do I
get in make my case and leave take
questions and leave and and so but you
know me I'd much rather be out there
with people because that's where I get
the greatest feel okay first of all not
the best choice of words for Joe Biden
you don't want to talk about how you
want to be around people because you can
feel them sort of a side point this is
so corrupt this answer is so
unbelievably corrupt the first part he
says I'm not going to hold rallies
meaning I'm not going to campaign
meaning it's the beginning setting the
stage for the excuse of why he's not
going to participate in a debate with
Donald Trump that's the first part if
he's not holding rallies it's not
holding a campaign then how on earth
could he go to a debate it's the same
point he says I just don't want to bring
people together in a physical location
so therefore I'm not gonna I'm not going
to campaign he's not gonna be able to
back out of the debate unless he starts
to set the stage now so that's the first
part why won't he debate Trump because
Trump would eat him for lunch there
would be nothing left other than Joe
Biden's very shiny teeth just said just
chattering there there is we got very
good looking to you I assume they're not
natural but that would be the last thing
left okay the second part why won't he
hold the campaign doctor's orders well
not just for me but for the country this
is something we've talked about now for
weeks which is that what the left does
is they exploit science capital as
trademark over the e to avoid politics
the whole thing Biden's been talking
about in this presser so you say
the doctor doctor's orders to the
country is we can't have a presidential
campaigning you just got to elect me no
actually that doctors don't diagnose
country's doctors diagnose individual
patients what you do political
demagogues like you diagnose countries
and tell them to just do whatever you
say she's saying in the name of science
we can't have a presidential campaign
this year but then he realized he is in
public he is doing a thing right now
right he actually is traveling around
the country occasionally at least to
raise a little bit of money at least to
make a comment here or comment there so
he has to back he goes and that's why
you know we all have to wear masks and
I'm gonna wear my mask just as soon as I
got off this stage it's like Andy Cuomo
yesterday shaming Trump for not wearing
a mask
Andy Cuomo himself wasn't wearing the
mask and that's why I'm not gonna bring
any people together in a room well I
mean I know I brought all of you
together in the room but that's because
it was politically convenient for me but
I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna do
that after this and I'm not gonna travel
I mean I know that I travel to some
places but I'm only gonna travel when
it's convenient for me it's all just BS
okay the whole thing is BS everyday this
lockdown this absolutely medically
pointless lockdown goes on is a point
you can take away from Donald Trump's
tally in the presidential race and a
point you can add to Joe Biden's tally
it's the only way they can win and it's
the only explanation for why the
lockdown is still going on what is the
other explanation they're talking about
how the cases are exploding sure but the
deaths are not the number of deaths are
not and the death rate is not and if the
whole point of the virus is we don't
have a cure for it we don't have a
vaccine then there's nothing the
lockdowns can do all you can do is Flint
the curve we already did that yeah I'm
so frustrated with Republican governors
and even some people on campaigns who
think that this is still about medical
science who think that this is a fair
playing field it's not it's a setup
folks gotta stop it okay I hope that
people from Republican campaigns
including the biggest one are listening
right now you have to run against the
lockdowns you've got to run hard against
the lockdowns the lockdown is the
entirety of Joe Biden's and the
Democrats campaigns you
if the Democrats had a capable candidate
who is articulate who they thought could
beat Donald Trump in a debate you can
bet your last dollar they would be
holding rallies every single week you
can bet it but they're not okay and so
they've got to walk back they've got to
lean back on an absolutely corrupted and
perverted exploitation of science enough
on that let's move on to the scientist
that where we've all come to exalt
doctor foul chief peace be upon him Rand
Paul figured this out Senator Rand Paul
who has been kind of snuffing this out
from the very beginning he was speaking
with the exalted dr. Fatih and he he
honed in on a point that I think is one
way that we're gonna be able to back
moderates and some liberals off from
their religious devotion to the
lockdowns that point is sending kids
back to school
all of this body of evidence about
schools around the world shows there's
no surge all of the evidence shows that
it's rare I mean we've so politicized
this and made it politically correct it
the w-h-o releases that it's rare and
you have a scientist up there honestly
giving her opinion what happens to her
she's blackballed and her a report that
she refers to is taken off the website
when you go to that that scientist
speech in you and you try to link on the
lick the WH o has now screened it from
us because it said something that's not
politically correct it guess what it's
rare for kids to transmit this but I
hear nothing of that coming from you all
I hear dr. pouches we can't do this we
can't do that we can't play baseball
even that's not based on the science I
mean flu season peaks in February we
don't know that kovat is gonna be like
the flu season it might but we don't
know that but we wouldn't we wouldn't
ban school in October you might close
some schools when they get the flu we
need to not mean to so from sumptuous
that we know everything we need to not
be so presumptuous that we know anything
that could sum up the whole error that
we're living in but as long as we are
living in this era where the the most
important thing to have is some
credential to say that you're part of
the scientific establishment don't
forget Rand Paul is a scientist right
he's a medical doctor and so it carries
extra weight when he lobbies these
criticisms I think he's honed in on a on
an important message here that
Republicans would do well to listen to
which is the schooling issue what's
gonna happen in the fall a lot of
colleges are not going to reopen as a
matter of fact you know I usually give
what eight or nine speeches on campus as
a semester those have virtually all of
them have been canceled so far because
we don't even know if the schools are
gonna reopen but colleges are the least
of it I mean sure I've got friends who
now are going to graduate school or who
now will have to do
zooom classes for college fine what
about people in high school or middle
school or elementary school what about
those students whose parents need to
figure out what's gonna happen to them
every single day there there are some
proposals going around in New York and
other plate let me show them at huge
school districts let's say they're gonna
reopen the schools only a little bit so
which obviously would serve no purpose
if you go to school even one day a week
or one day a month even you're going to
be exposed to the virus and it's not
going to achieve anything but some of
the proposals are they're going to go in
person to school two days a week and
then they're gonna be home from school
three days a week and do it on zoom' so
medically achieves nothing but
economically how is that supposed to
work just to use the example of New York
City if you are a parent in New York
City it is a statistical certainty that
you work you have to work because it's a
very expensive place to live and very
very expensive place to raise kids so
the parents there are working what are
they supposed to do they're gonna call
in their boss and say hey I'm gonna need
off three days a week I can't tell you
what the three days are by the way yet
and I'm not sure when it's going to be
set but I'm gonna need that so I'm gonna
start working two days a week now is
that cool with you imagine if you called
your boss and said that probably would
not go over very well as a practical
matter you can't do it this is why from
the beginning the the lockdown
proponents have been trying to figure
out the school issue because they know
they actually said in Los Angeles they
said we're I think we'll throughout all
of California we're not going to reopen
churches until phase
three but we're gonna try to reopen
schools in Phase two or its phase 4
versus Phase three or whatever they knew
that they had to reopen the the schools
early because there's just this first of
all they want to keep indoctrinating
your kids but second of all there's just
this very practical matter of you don't
know what to do with the kids whereas
they felt they could put off allowing
people to go back to their churches for
a longer time this would be a good one
to hammer home on you know there was a
decision that came out from the Supreme
Court yesterday finally some slightly
good news from the Supreme Court that is
more permissive of school choice and of
religious schools and you know in a week
that's been very trying or two weeks
it's been very try on the Supreme Court
at least this opened the door to school
choice a little bit why because school
choice is very popular it's always been
a good wedge issue for Republicans to
talk to demographics that don't usually
vote for them and it's a good a good
issue here in the lockdowns I at this
point I'm convinced that the Supreme
Court just makes their decisions not by
reading the law but by looking at public
opinion polling and then whatever is
really popular that's going to be the
decision that they push for in many many
cases so I think you can actually use
that to your advantage here when you're
talking about
the whether or not we're going to reopen
anything just say like hey where are
they gonna make you send your kids
they're not gonna let you go back to
work they're not gonna let your kid get
an education there I think if you focus
on that for long enough you're you're
going to be able to win over some of
those moderate where the suburban women
the the people at the very few people in
the middle who don't have a decision yet
about this presidential election
another great wedge issue here is
another public institution not the
schools it's the police how many times
have you been told
ever since Democrats brought up this
idea of defunding the police that
defunding the police doesn't really mean
defunding the police oh you fool
you think defunding the police youth and
when I said I meant to defund the police
no no it means to move the budgets
around and reallocate resources and well
AOC just came out and exposed that lie
completely she said quote defund
police means defunding police she issued
a press release on this yesterday
congresswoman Alexandria Cassio cortez
defunding police means defunding police
it does not mean budget tricks or funny
math it does not mean moving school
police officers from the NYPD budget to
the Department of Education budget so
that the exact same police remain in
schools it does not mean counting
overtime cuts as cuts even as NYPD
ignores every attempt by City Council to
curb overtime spending and over - over
spends on overtime anyway
she wrote anyways AOC it does not mean
hiring more police officers while
cutting more than 800 million dollars
from New York City public schools if
these reports are accurate then these
proposed cuts to NYPD's budget or a
disingenuous illusion this is not a
victory the fight to defund policing
continues I love her so often I love I
love this congressman because she might
have terrible ideas for the country but
at least she tells you what she thinks
remember with the green New Deal she put
forward the green New Deal which is a
radical transformative Marxist policy
idea that has actually very little to do
with the natural environment has a lot
to do with vast redistribution of wealth
nationalizing industries reparations
programs health care programs all this
kind of stuff and when she put that
forward 93 trillion dollar plan over ten
years Mitch McConnell Senate Majority
Leader came out and said we got a vote
on this immediately I want to get all
you Democrats on the record about this
green New Deal immediately well she's
doing that same thing again with
defunding the police a very very
unpopular position right now we're
looking at New York City yesterday in
New York this there was this big budget
fight to see whether they were gonna
defund the police or not mass gathering
huge gathering outside of City Hall it
was it was so jubilant people gathered
together in this large group at one
point they just started dancing
you
that mass gathering by the way totally
fine coronavirus not going to spread it
all if you want to have a presidential
debate or a campaign rally or go to the
beach on the 4th of July that is gonna
spread coronavirus but if you want to
dance around outside of city hall and
try to destroy the New York City Police
Department best Police Department in the
country that is totally fine just
another little example of how SuperDuper
serious coronavirus is from a medical
perspective so scientific perspective
pandemic can't hold a presidential
election so they're dancing around
outside and they get their budget cut 1
billion dollars cut 1 billion with a be
cut from the NYPD's six billion dollar
operating budget that's a that's a huge
percentage particularly as crime and
shootings are way up they are on the
rise and it's not just New York cutting
LAPD also cut a lot of money from the
budget not quite like NYPD but the LA
City Council passed a motion two to one
cut 150 million dollars pass from the
police budget and also to replace the
Los Angeles Police Department officers
with unarmed quote crisis response
personnel to be assigned to nonviolent
calls for service such as neighbor
disputes I the the Orwellian politically
correct jargon here is really something
to behold they're going to have crisis
response personnel for nonviolent calls
for service now the thing about
non-violent calls for service is
sometimes they turn violent sometimes
violent calls for service also known as
when you call the cops start out not
very violent this motion was introduced
by la councilman Herb Wesson and five
other colleagues on the 15-member LA
City Council and Wesson said he would be
working with on the project with members
of black lives matter in Los Angeles
black lives matter a Marxist
organization that seeks to destroy the
Western proscribed nuclear family their
words not mine and wants to defund
police entirely so what they're doing
though is they're going to take away
resources from the cops crime is going
to go up shootings are going to go up
they're gonna go on and they're gonna
put it in fake cops some new kind of
cops that they're calling crisis
response personnel well how is that
going to work out we have an example
from the chop
remember the chop I thought the chop was
over chop Chazz the the occupied zone
and Seattle apparently it's still going
on people are still being killed there
by the anarchists when you replace the
police first of all when you defund the
police you don't just defund the police
it gets replaced with something that's
what we're seeing in LA in the chop what
it gets replaced with is roving gangs
and unbelievably the chop which was
established putatively because of police
brutality and they wanted to stop police
brutality while they set up their own
police force and that police force is
now shooting black teenagers and killing
them it's so it's so ironic you can't
say it's funny but it's so darkly ironic
you you you almost can't even react to
it a 16 year old fatally shot in the
chop on Monday morning a 14 year old a
child is in critical condition at the
Harborview Medical Center and a
volunteer medic you know they don't have
doctors in the job because it's an
independent country they've got
volunteer medics said that it was the
chopped security forces who shot the
black teenager
the irony is almost too much this person
also described chopped as an active war
zone well the chop is a little crystal
ball my friends if the chop policy is
begin to be passed in actual cities
around the country in Los Angeles and
New York then we're going to see our
cities turn into active war zones for
the near future it's already happening
crime is already on the rise this is
another from a political perspective
good thing for conservatives to talk
about because what it looks like our
cities are headed into is the 1970s
urban decay death mayhem destruction
poverty this led to some Republicans it
most notably Rudy Giuliani in New York
getting elected in the 90s and cleaning
it up because it doesn't matter what you
say your political affiliation is and
your ideology and
when you've got people dropping like
flies around you and you when you're
afraid to leave your apartment at night
you're gonna want a little bit of law
and order a good point to focus on one
because it could save lives before it
gets too bad and two from a political
perspective it's it's one way to exploit
what the left is using as their
exploitation you want to hit your
opponent in politics at the weak point
right and so right now Donald Trump's
entire campaign is rallies right he
holds these stand-up specials when he
goes to give these rallies the rest of
the campaign that is not quite as strong
as Trump himself and so what did what
are the Democrats do they take Trump's
best campaign platform segment
opportunity they take it off the table
so now he's just got the rest of his
otherwise not that great campaign now
what can we do we can use what they are
doing we can use that against them on at
least those two issues on schools and on
cops there was a there was a study just
came out Siena College Research
Institute found 57% of New Yorkers New
Yorkers opposed reducing any reducing
funding at all for the police and 60
percent said that they opposed defunding
the police that was in a separate
question that's even in New York so a
good one to hit them on we will get to
what happens as this continues we will
also get to the the rancor I mean we
looked at the crystal ball of the Chazz
we'll look at the crystal ball of the
college campuses in just one second
first though I've got to thank you
because you have allowed my YouTube
channel to blow past the hundred
thousand subscriber mark we're now past
115 thousand subscribers so thank you
you can check out all the bonus content
on that channel and I also have to make
one last request of you we're one spot
behind pod save America on the Apple
podcast charts and I really don't like
those guys the liberal pod bros the
Obama alumni and so I would really like
to blow past them that would that would
just be terrific so if you wouldn't mind
please go over and subscribe on Apple
podcasts to the Michael Nolt show
guest and leaving a five-star review and
would greatly appreciate that if you're
not already a daily why remember
consider getting a reader's pass at
daily wire calm great value for only 3
bucks a month and when you sign up you
get that first month for only 99 cents
you also get access to exclusive
editorials and lots of fun content this
one from Matt Walsh activist once
imagined to be our new anthem it's the
worst song ever written you know Matt is
always so subtle he's always so you
never know quite where Matt Walsh stands
so anyway you get great content like
that great election insight head on over
to Daley wire.com sign up for just a
buck we'll be right back with a lot more
Ernest Hemingway famously pointed out
that things happen gradually then
suddenly I think politics is heating up
it is accelerating at a pace that we are
not used to in this country and so a lot
of people don't realize the ground has
completely shifted and we need to
recognize that frankly even Joe Biden
doesn't fully comprehend well he doesn't
fully comprehend very much but he
doesn't fully comprehend how much the
ground has shifted in politics so for
instance he was he was asked a question
about the statues should we pull down
Jefferson and Lee and all that and he
gave this answer that is going to please
absolutely no one he tried to walk this
line between what he views as the
establishment of his party and the
radicals of his party because he thinks
that those those two groups are not that
far apart actually they are so separated
and in this country right now the two
sides are so separated you can't walk
that line and if you stand in the middle
of the road you're gonna get hit by a
truck listen to how Joe Biden tries to
please everybody I think those statues
belong in museums they don't belong in
public places and I think with regard to
those statues that are and monuments
like the Jefferson Memorial whatever I
think there's an obligation that the
that the government protect those
monuments because they're different than
that's a remembrance
it is not a dealing with
revering somebody who had that view they
much broader views they may have things
in their past that are now and then
distasteful but that's a judgment for
the console for example taking down
toppling Christopher Columbus statue or
George Washington's statue or etc I
think that is something that is the
government has an opportunity and a
responsibility to protect from happening
so the government has a responsibility
to protect Jefferson who was a far more
notorious slaver than a guy like say
robert e lee but now robert e lee y
actually i mean take it to an even
further conclusion which is the BLM
movemen the hard left in america they
think the country is rotten to the core
they think that the founding was
hopelessly rotten that's the thesis of
the 16:19 project so isn't it the case
that that the the founders of this
country are the most culpable forget
about robert e lee he was just a general
who you know he was a union general and
then when virginia pulled away he went
down and and fought for virginia and
then he gave up the battle and was an
honorable guy after the war and forget
about him he's a he's a sidenote really
if you really believe the 16:19 project
in BLM's marxist premises and the
radical left you should most want to
topple Jefferson and Washington Columbus
discovered the whole hemisphere so
certainly Columbus has to come down Joe
Biden's answer like so many of Joe
Biden's answers doesn't make any sense
he's trying to walk that line and I
think some Republicans are trying to
walk this line too they're trying to
walk a line they're trying to play
politics ten years ago when things were
a little bit more reasonable when there
was at least the facade of an objective
press when the Democratic Party in this
country and Democratic leaders at least
pretended to like America they weren't
openly protesting the American flag they
weren't calling the the 4th of July a
white supremacist holiday they did that
they actually did that which we'll get
to in just one second that's gone ok
that's over we are now at the
we're half of this country's political
leaders protests the American flag they
don't like the country where we have
roving gangs of anarchists setting the
country on fire torching things and the
elected Democrats egging them on
encouraging them saying that's a good
just wonderful cause where we have
self-admitted trained Marxists talking
openly about how they want to destroy
the nuclear family and elected Democrats
that frankly the entire elected
establishment embracing it saying yes we
support this group you you can't you
can't thread that needle guys you have
to pick aside and this is true on the
statue toppling Joe Biden's gonna have
to pick a side on that I mean luckily
Joe Biden is all for him luckily he's
got all of the institutional support
behind him so he gets away with a lot
more Republicans they don't have that
advantage so on something like the lock
downs you can't run on it a little bit
okay maybe we want to open in 15 days
well actually it's gonna be 30 days and
I'd like to open by Easter but I don't
know if we can and we're gonna relock
down again and in Texas we're gonna
locked in again
no let pick a side guys what is it is it
gonna be you're gonna totally lock down
and just give up on this presidential
election and I don't know try again in
ten years or something or are you gonna
actually stand up recognize what is
happening to you politically and fight
back we just need I just wish people saw
what was going on and I know on
political campaigns they get stuck in
bubbles so they don't see it but for the
rest of us out here who are not just in
a campaign office in a campaign bubble
the country is burning to the ground we
are in a unique moment uncharted
territory at least in recent memory and
the person who wins is going to be the
one who is most aware of what is going
on right now I mean we have in Detroit
there was a there was a video that came
out yesterday of mobs swarming a cop car
beating the cop car smashing its windows
and so the cop starts driving sort of
slowly and then obviously when he starts
driving and and won't let the mob
totally overtake the car then they start
going completely crazy he's just trying
to jerk out of there he's not actually
not running over anybody is just trying
to get out of there finally he he makes
it out and this is being reported this
is seriously being reported as mostly
peaceful protestors surrounding the car
and the cop drove into them of course
the cop is completely justified into in
driving through this crowd you can't
expect a cop to just an there and say
okay come kill me guys come kill me
raging mob and yet so many people in
this country the completely straight
face say yeah it's just a just a group
of peaceful protesters you've got a gal
at Harvard Harvard senior who it just
made a u-turn about Harvard University
theoretically one of the elite
universities in the country this Harvard
senior makes a video in which she says
that if you use the phrase all lives
matter instead of black lives matter
then she is going to stab you next
person who has the sheer nerve the sheer
entitled capacity to say all lives
matter
i'ma stab you I'm gonna stab you and
while you're struggling and bleeding out
i'ma show you my paper cut and say my
cut matters too did you hear that word
she said call Cassidy the word caucus
she was referring to whiteness is you
call caste like Caucasian she's using
the word whiteness the term whiteness as
an insult now imagine if you did that
with any other race you would be kicked
out of polite society it'd be
investigated for a hate crime do you
think that this miss girl is gonna face
any disciplinary action at Harvard no I
I don't I think she'll probably get an
award at graduation meanwhile there's a
student at Kansas State University who's
being threatened with expulsion because
he tweeted a disrespectful joke about
George Floyd it's a kind of use it's a
it's a the often used joke I mean this
is an old joke that goes back very far
the the joke is that George Floyd is now
has now been drug-free since he died you
know but it's it's a joke that was came
up when Whitney Houston died it comes up
whenever a celebrity who is a famous
drug user dies people say this it's very
disrespectful I you know I don't
think it's a little too soon I don't
think we should be telling jokes about
people who have been killed like that
shortly after but this kid is now being
threatened with expulsion for telling a
not very nice old joke this girl is
going to face no consequences for
threatening to stab people for being
white and for saying the phrase all
lives matter now you could say she's
telling a joke - okay well the other guy
was telling a joke her joke is more
offensive there her joke is far more
aggressive and threatening but that is
the kind of aggressive double standard
culture that we are living in right now
a Washington Post editor just called for
revenge against white women a Washington
Post editor just came out and said the
lies and tears of white women hath
wrought the 1921 Tulsa Massacre the
murder of Emmett Till exclusion of black
women from feminist movements 53 percent
of white women voting for Trump I mean
it's just really really throwing
everything at the wall here white women
are lucky that we're just calling them
Karan's which is a racial term it's a
sort of like funny one but it is a
racial term and not calling for revenge
this is not patience and strength it's
the result of knowing the price of
resistance and that much that much blood
would be spilt we must get away from the
idea that enduring abuse is admirable
I'm just saying be happy we're calling
for equality and not actual revenge
well what I'm hearing these days is not
any call for equality from the left I'm
hearing calls for revenge which is why
they're burning down the country and
killing people so it is explicitly a
call for revenge I want to focus though
on that line she said this is an editor
of The Washington Post she says we must
get away from the idea that enduring
abuse is admirable also known as the
Christian understanding of suffering the
idea that we suffer and suffering can be
sanctifying this is this is how our
civilization traditionally has
understood suffering I mean even other
ancient understandings of suffering is
that we all suffer there is there is no
utopian political solution to the world
there will be pain and we must endure
that pain and that
Payne deepens our character and shapes
us and can be we can either react to
that in a good ennobling way or we can
react to that in a de basing way this is
obviously the case but for leftist
utopians they think that any suffering
is an affront to what they deserve they
they don't deserve any pain in the world
are you kidding I mean they look these
these are people who celebrate pride for
an entire month the American Left pride
the deadliest of the seven deadly sins
so they just are not equipped for the
the simple fact of the human condition
that there is suffering and you will
suffer and suffering actually can be a
helpful thing in your in your character
development they don't they they just
want to abolish it which is never going
to happen and it's why they get more and
more frustrated as it happens Democrats
are now I'm not just saying one or two
random Democrats I'm saying the
Democratic Party is now referring to the
fourth of July is a white supremacist
holiday they tweeted out because
President Trump is planning to hold a
rally at Mount Rushmore they tweeted out
quote Trump has disrespected Native
communities time and again he's
attempted to limit their voting rights
and blocked critical pandemic relief not
true but whatever now he is holding a
rally glorifying white supremacy at
Mount Rushmore a region once sacred to
tribal communities what does that mean
I'm sure the I'm sure the place that the
Democratic National Committee office is
on was once sacred to Native American
communities in the sense that there were
Native Americans before Europeans
settled to the continent but forget that
double standard - they're referring to a
fourth of July rally as a white
supremacist rally now some people are
saying no no the Democrats are just
referring to Mount Rushmore as a white
supremacist site which again doesn't
that still doesn't make any sense do you
think Abraham Lincoln is a white
supremacist the man who freed the slaves
I don't think so
George Washington Thomas Jefferson all
you call them white supremacist I don't
think so
really what they mean is they're white
guys and all white people white white is
bad now and all white people are white
supremacist that's really what the left
is saying that's really what that
Harvard girl is saying but that's
actually not that's not even the
Democrats point here because the
Democrats are saying Trump is holding a
rally glorifying white supremacy at
Mount Rushmore Mount Rushmore is just
the site of the rally glorifying white
supremacy well what's the rally
glorifying white supremacy its trump's
fourth of July rally so the thing that
they are a cute if you just parse the
sentence the thing that they are
accusing of being white supremacists is
the 4th of July which is not surprising
to anyone who's been paying attention
anyone who has realized what's going on
the left has captured all of the
institutions of this country including
and especially the Democratic Party they
hate this country they hate it with a
burning passion a passion that burns so
hot that it's now burning down cities
and they want to tear it down anyone who
listened when Barack Obama said I want
to fundamentally transform America may
have realized huh I guess he doesn't
like America all that much because you
don't want to fundamentally transform
things that you like anyone who is
listening who is reading the New York
Times 16:19 project was listening who's
been watching as they've been tearing
down the statues we are in a
particularly radical moment you hear
every presidential campaign is the most
important campaign of our lifetimes in a
way it's always true because things
happen gradually then suddenly so you're
getting closer and closer to some real
danger the danger is here police
departments are going away cities are on
fire they want to blow up Mount Rushmore
people have joking with somewhat
jokingly and then somewhat earnestly
suggested that the danger is here if if
we don't rise to this occasion as a
political matter we might not get
another shot you see how the deck is
stacked against here the Supreme Court
in the administrative government in
everywhere hope springs eternal in the
human breast you can try to fight again
in ten years or twenty years maybe
you'll be able to claw something back
but I think
realizing at this moment we're a major
political party is calling the fourth of
July a white supremacist terrible
holiday trying to cancel it I think we
realized that we're on the verge of
something really being lost our history
our culture our cities our country
itself will we rise to the occasion or
will we realize it all too late I hope
it's the former I hope people are
listening to the show today all right
we've got a lot more we'll get to it
tomorrow I'm Micah Knowles as the mic-n
old show see you then the Michael Noel's
show is produced by Ben Davies executive
producer Jeremy borin supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders hair
and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over at the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
Andrew clip
you